when i went to pick up the phone today i
had already gotten word that jeff was
angry with me again because i wasn't
picking up the phone enough
on him and and i have explained to him
20 billion times
i i i it's he's not the whole show he
doesn't
get it you picked up on king
you picked the price i pick up on other
people and yes you know yes
that's right that's right it's not a
democratic process
jeff it's not so damn well i'm part of
the [ __ ] show
people people ask me all the [ __ ]
time
why don't you crawl into the show
anymore we'd love to hear from you
how don't take my [ __ ] calls
i saw you were up on the phone and your
topic was
saturday night live chris rock did you
watch
you know there were better people on the
phone quite honestly
[Music]
um that's never been you're
you're debating my judgment when you get
a jeff the drunk show you can pick up on
who you want i don't always pick up on
you and you've got to deal with it
you just got to well let me explain
something to jeff
it's called the howard stern show
and so no one talks to excuse me jeff
listen
i'm listening howard talks to who he
wants to talk to
end of story
wait when robin yells at you that even
shuts him the [ __ ] up [ __ ] crazy